[music]
can you tell me what you were
arrested for? I was a member of the Ukrainian
underground, which fought against the Polish
government and also the Soviet Union,
but I was not
physically very active here.
I didn't know what I was
arrested for.
this and Volodymyr's
appeal in Poland
was simply an investigation
in Warsaw on mokotov and then I was
transferred to Kyiv in Kyiv I was tried
there almost even interrogated and given
10 years with a
weapon in my hands and this one but I never held a weapon in my
life
but  tried
for the
Ukrainian underground. And for this enterprise
in Kyiv, I went by train practically
to
Khabarovsk, Khabarovsk Territory, and already
above the rule of the exit sea, we were traveling,
or did the sea have to move from
Khabarovsk to Magadan,
and from there we were unloaded by self-propelled trucks to
various camps?  there were constants, just a
collection of which in Sambor, there were a
lot of them
not far from the city of Magadan,
a lonely place that at that time was read to be
practically developed and there were
camps, they were quite far from you, the closest there was
Boje RK Gola, and
Magadan was a port city, you
came to Magadan and actually unloaded from there  in the
camps, well, there, the
mines were physically working, the mines, the
pits, that is, before the special year of
extraction
[music] of the
wealth of the earth,
such judges worked because the
normal mines went to the mines in the mountains, they went to
build them in the Valley of pits, and later
the demolition is
far reaching and then it is necessary to clean  and to
go into the ground again,
constant acid, hard work. Well,
there were different ones,
so you fell down, the wood was
piled up, then transported,
it depends on whether it’s winter or summer. In winter,
for example,
self-propelled trucks with trees
just push the frames with our shoulders in teams,
we went to work, for example, we
definitely already  I don't remember about
the administration, it was every hour we
went out, everyone gave us that Ganges, I know that they
killed us in such
a tire, they
killed us with iron here, everyone went to
breakfast
and got a portion of bread somewhere like this
when 800 g of bread a day
and then went to work, it depends on who  for
which he worked, which were not far from Zlagra, then
they would rather go to the house, which
means that the Barrack of barracks is a normal
Barrack, and so if in English there are
also normal solid bunks, wooden
or something.
The camp, then we
returned to Oleg for lunch, if
further Well, then obviously some rations were delivered to us
or not delivered and in the evening
we ate like here a second one for lunch.  rather, I
was in barrels to the barracks, water was brought,
so whoever came sooner had
the water, if not, well, it had to be done
somehow. Well, of course, the
majority came immediately to the barracks
to take water from those big barrels
that were there, they
changed and gave us  in the winter, felt boots are
heavy, so they didn't look at the
leg there, we simply later
exchanged more, less,
to buy small ones, obviously, for the winter, for the
summer, he gave us boots.
they were sent there for crimes. Yes, there
were many.
We were in the political camp
before.  there
were very few of those criminals,
maybe one got a
political article, then it was
our brigade, but that’s normal. Then we
would be political ourselves,
and it was even better to see each other for a
meal. After work,
we came late, so there was
no socializing.  there was time, but if
there was a day off or two hours,
well, they tried to get out of those
pricks,
interesting,
interested in checking the solution,
there were people of different
heights, come
closer, for example, there were also doctors and
professors, and well, of all kinds, from which you
could even  and use a lot
simply
[music]
those people were
not enough We had time for it there, but we found everything
and there were those who were worth drawing, tried
to get paper and so on, but that’s all
after work But so that it wouldn’t be so
big Although there was also and even was
amateur club
treacherous camp, but the prisoners played there, you
could not go out. For example, I
used
this
[music]
with the music of the zone, how was it
done? We were normal. In such pieces of paper, we
howled like how
at such balls of paper, something, and we
were late for the
letter to the as if we
left  on foot in Magadanka and he
dropped a note that he would like to
correspond with someone with girls
directly to support each other in
these
it also depends
[music]
with whom you corresponded, he was also a
political prisoner, by the way, a former
soldier of the
Soviet Union, then he reached  even
to Berlin, but there someone said something about him. He
said that he wanted to stay in
Austria. On the way, when they were dying, they already
went to win
him from the spot. They arrested him and immediately
took him to the Don Rylsky ahead, and
practically those soldiers who seemed to be
guilty of those Soviet army were
there.  they took the cut and they practically
opened it in Norilsk, the first Lara,
he from Norilsk later got to the
carpets and we were late with the letter carrier, the whole
story of this and that delay is because it was
completely I never saw him in my life
until the very end
we corresponded to correspond
depends on who is what is
very interesting
Correspondence I have to go
until now and
so I was not late,
everyone thought that we would meet someday, but
in the meantime I was brought to Poland naked
as they were brought and now I told
him tomorrow where I am
and we continued to correspond, but we knew
that it was impossible, he was far away in Asia and
Tashkent is in a tashket,
so he came down with loose
promises and on the contrary said that if someone
goes out into the field,
then you are free until the second
and so we would not have seen today when but
they were put forward until he got married and
until his wife just wanted somewhere
for herself  so
that we corresponded
so that he died in the 14th year,
I left for England,
we were friends. We first got to know each other
later, I think that if we were quite enough,
we would probably have
gotten married,
but that's how it happened,
how it happened,
so that cleaning together the Soviet Union, I'm
Nastia  then it was as if I was in Ukraine for seven
years, and I don't remember being there for a month.
Well, when they
brought me, I'll say it to the
carpets, that's how they returned it. When we're on
the road, it's not like I'm free. Still like a prisoner, but
already in  In Poland, when we arrived in White
Podlaska, we were already overheard by the
Polish police once and then they let us go
free,
so it was practically almost 8 years, so
all together
they gave me 10 years, so I am
more likely because
that old man and this one died,
and that's it  so
if you look back at everything
you had to go through, do you regret that you
joined the nationalist movement and
everything ended the way it ended?
and we were Ukrainians, now she
will destroy you,
whether it was the bushes at that time, whether it was
communist,
or whether it was in the Soviet Union,
we knew what he was fighting for. And the question is,
what are your thoughts on the war, what is
Russia's situation with Ukraine now, what do you think about
our struggle now?
Listen, I believe  that
Ukrainians are the ones who
defend Ukraine. It is true that heroes of
heroes do not fight for the truth
against an enemy that has always been our enemy,
not now, now they are fighting for their
state, which is, which exists and fights for
the truth heroically,
no one even expected that there is
so much
love for that land
by what happened, it's good that there's no point in taking off, you have to
move forward, life goes on if you can choose a
better life
[music]
it's like having a good time Well,
not everything here seems to be
[music]
you see